Selamlar sevgili arkadaşlar. Umarım
iyisinizdir. Sağlık, sıat yerindedir. E
çalıştığınız ekiplerde emeğinizin
karşısını alıyorsunuzdur umarım. İş
arıyorsanız güzel iş fırsatları sizinle
gelmiştir, gelecektir. Eee, varsa
çalıştığınız ya da yazdığınız kodlarda
problemler umarım iyi en hızlı şekilde
fikslenecektir diye şöyle iyi
dileklerimizi verelim. Dünyaya sonra
devam edelim. Arkadaşlar eee birlikte
bir ufak seriye başlamıştık. Bu serideki
amacım bozuk veya böyle eski veya
problemli bir projede neler yapabiliriz,
neleri güncelleyebiliriz adında bir
seriydi. E yaklaşık 40-45 dakikalık bir
tane videodan önden atmıştım. Bugün
şimdi o videonun ilk partını
başlayacağız. Küçük küçük şuradaki
adımları üzerinden geçe geçe
ilerleyeceğiz. Bunları yapıp projemizin
ileride nelere geldiğini, buradan nelere
ilerlediğimizi birlikte görüyor olacağız
arkadaşlar. Şimdi benim hemen doğrudan
geçiyorum. İlk part dediğim gibi eğer
videoyu yayınlüyorsanız muhakkak ilk
parti izlemenizde fayda var. Orada bu
detayları daha uzun uzun verdim. Şimdi
ben direkt buradan başlayarak ilerliyor
olacağım arkadaşlar. Şimdi benim bugün
eleme ele alacağım konulardan bir tanesi
pubamel kontrolü, analiz option ve vs
code settings ayarları. Şimdi şöyle
bunun dediğim gibi eee bu konuların
detaylarını ben zaten videonun diğer
videonun yani şeyinde anlattım bunları
niye girdiğimi. Onun için çok burada
girmeyeceğim. Doğrudan işe geçerek
ilerleyeceğim. Şimdi bu tarz projelerde
PUSP yamal gerçekten bizim için en
önemli noktalardan bir tanesi oluyor.
Çünkü projenin gidişatı, nerelere
gideceği vesairesinin yanı sıra aslında
kullandığımız paketler ve
geliştirmelerimiz bu noktada bizim için
oldukça önemli ve geliştirme konusunda
dikkat etmemiz gereken noktada oluyor.
Şimdi arkadaşlar burada öncelikle PU SPC
yamel tarafında bizim yapmamız gereken
hareketler şunlar. Biz şu bir kere
şeyden kurtulalım. Şu tam yani aslında
bunları empte etsem gerek yok da bunları
buradan kurtaralım. Şimdi bizim burada
en önemli olarak bilmemiz gereken iki
tane nokta var. Bir dependency kısmımız
var. Bir dev kısmımız var. Ve muhtemelen
eee projenizin ilerleme durumuna göre
veya yapacağınız e geliştirmelere göre
de bir dependency override kısmımız
olacak arkadaşlar. Bu da bazı t
senaryolarderde çok işimize yarayan bir
property. Eee bunun da üzerine dediğim
gibi bir yine ilerleyen örneklerde belki
bir demo yapar anlatırız ama bazı
senelerde kurtaracak. Şimdi ondan
bahsediyor olacağım. Şimdi arkadaşlar
bizim öncelikle bu dependi kısımlarını
bir topluyor olmamız lazım. Projenin
ilerlemesi, projenin paketlerinin doğru
yönetilmesi ilk başta her şey doğru
çalışır zaten. Bu ileriye yönelik bir
kodlamaya ilk adım olduğu için burada
bizim özellikle dikkat etmemiz gereken
şey annotation'larla elimizden geldiği
kadarıyla paketleri veya kullanım
sayarına göre yerlerini doğru tutmamız
gerekiyor. Mesela file base paketleri
muhtemelen zaten 10 tane falan oluyor.
Bunları bir yerde toplamak önemli. yarın
bir update attığımızda veya bunları
tabii paket isim bazlı değil ama util
gibi mesela for example bir tane eee
view utils
bunun içerisine gelirsin dersin ki hocam
ben lot ile shimmer'ı şuraya alacağım
dersin ve bu sayede aslında viewlerinin
toplandığı yer veya view'e ihtiyacım
varsa böyle şimdi burada 30 tane paket
olacağı projeler göreceksiniz okunma
ihtimali çok düşüyor. Bunları burada
toplamak onun için çok önemli. Mesela
database dediğimiz
kısmı buraya alırsak buna göre kendini
kurtar olacak. Veya burada servis
logiklerimiz, network logiclerimiz varsa
bunları burada toplamamız bizim için
önemli. Mesela burada bizim bir diğer
kullanım sayarımızdaki işlemimizde
mesela package info plus gibi native
bağımlılıklı olanları aslında bakın bu
da önemli bir detaydır. Şimdi mesela
flutterın içerisinde mesela Firebase'in
de native bağımlılığı var gerçi ama
birçok paket mesela kamera plugini
vesaire bunların native bağımlılığı olan
third party paketler. Şimdi bir third
party paket var. Bir de native bağımlılı
paketler var. Bunları ayırmak önemli.
Çünkü eee flutter paketlerinin yanı sıra
native paketler bazen pod durumlarından,
grade durumlarından hatalar verebiliyor.
Bunları da bir yerde yönetmek adına
kullanıyor olacağız. Şimdi bu birincisi.
Bu önemli, basit ama önemli. Burada
önemli olan bir diğer nokta, projenin
sağlığına göre dikkat edeceğiniz nokta
arkadaşlar şu şapka kullanımları. Şimdi
bu şapka kullanımları gerçekten üzerine
yine ilerlediğimiz zamana da
göreceksiniz projenin dediğim gibi
ilerlediği şartte. Mesela ben burada
Loti'yi kullandığım san bunu ekledim.
For example bu çalışıyor ve ben bunu
teste de verdim ve release'e aldım.
paket çıktım vesaire verdim ama yarın
geldi bir release bir paket daha çıktım.
LTI'nin çalışıp çalışmamayacağı
noktasında veya release paketine doğru
olup olmayacağını komit edemem. Çünkü
arkadaşlar şapka attığım için yeni bir
versiyon çıktıysa yeni bir PUBG
atıldığında herhangi bir sorun yoksa
yeni versiyonu otomatik geçecektir
arkada. Şimdi burada şu noktada hemfikir
olmanız gerekiyor. Benim size önerim
release paketlerinizi çıkarken ha bunu
sen yapabiliyor musun de. Şu ana kadar
tam bunu uygulayamadık ama işte yavaş
yavaş bunları da uygulatmaya
çalışıyorum. Ekiplerimde ya da
yapacağımız yerlerde release
paketlerinde doğru çıktığınız
senaryolarda hangi versiyonlarda
hepinizin olduğunun farkında olup
şapkalarını kaldırmanız gerekiyor.
Bununla ilgili bir script de var elimde
de. Siz de bunu bir eğer vesaire
oluşturursunuz. Şapkaları kaldırıp
release döneminde yeni versiyon gelince
almayı entegre edecek şekilde gitmeniz
çok önemli. Bu sayede o mesela release
birinde 2 gün testler yapılıyor vesaire.
İki gün önceki versiyonda, 2 gün sonraki
versiyonda Firebase pakette sorundan da
bir problem olup crash çıkabilir mesela.
Dikkatli olmakta fayda var. Şimdi bu dev
dependency noktası da arkadaşlar bizim
yine uğrak duraklarımızdan bir tanesi
olacak. Burada mesela biz bazı Linter
paketlerimizi ki bu da bizim için yine
mesela şuradan bir tanesini hemen açacak
olursak arkadaşlar şurada pde devimizden
eee mesela linterımıza gidelim. Mesela
bir linter paketinin bu linter ne ya?
Şey nerede benim? Very good analiz.
Benim en çok sevdiğim
zaten. Onu birazdan ekleyecektim. Alayım
şuraya.
Very good yazsam gelir zaten. Aynen.
Very good. Ekibinin analiz toolunu
mesela ekleyeceğiz. Şimdi buraya da
zaten bizim buradaki ana noktamızda
arkadaşlar projenin release hattında
kullanılmayacak. Sadece debug time'da ya
da işte proje bu halinde kullanılacak
paketlerimizi ekliyoruz. Burada da doğru
yere doğru pakete eklemekte fayda var.
Mesela en çok kullanılan ve dikkat
edilmesi gereken y mesela bir Jason
annotation kullanıyorsanız ve Jason
Cellilizable vardır iki tane paket.
Fakat aslında proje Jason Cellizable'ı
kullanmaz. Jason annotation'dır. Sizin
un noktanız Jason Calilizable boot
generation için lazımdır mesela gibi
veya boot generation demişken
geldiğimizde boot runner üzerine de
zaten bu yamul dosyalarının üzerine
konuştuğumda anlatacağım bunları
arkadaşlar. Bu runner kısmını. Bu
runner'ı entegre ettiğiniz noktayı da
şöyle şuraya alacak olursam hop mesela
boot runner gibi işlemleri burada
topluyor. Burada önemli olan
başlıklardan bir tanesi bu dependency
overhead kısmı. Bu dependency over kısmı
şurada işinize yarayacak. Mesela 2i tane
paket kullanıyorsunuz. Alt modülerikler
yaptınız. Bir şeyler bağladınız. Fakat
eee bazı versiyonlarda e kullanmanız
gereken mesela diyelim ki Lint'ten bir
paketten bir conflict yiyorsunuz ve ama
diyorsunuz ki ben bunun şu versiyonunu
kullanacağım projede ve bunda sorun yok
diyorsunuz. Bu noktada dependence
override'ı kullanarak bazı durumlarda
for example ben işte Flutter Lins'in şu
versiyonunu kullan diyorum. Şimdi bunu
verdiğim an şu oluyor. Projenin alt
modüllerinde, üst modüllerinde nerede
olursa olsun bunu kullanan bütün
paketler kendini otomatik olarak buraya
çekmiş oluyor. Yani ben o dependency'yi
over ediyorum. Kullandığım paketi
açısından bütün her yerde varsa da
overht ediyorum. Çok efektif kullanmanız
gereken noktalar oluşmaması isterim ama
bazı T senaryoları da işinize yarıyor.
Paket versiyonlarını da kurtarıyor
olabilir. Şu anlık bizim bir başlığımız
değil. Bu burada kalsın ama hani ben
şurada göstermek anlamında bırakacağım
ama burada kalsın. Şimdi buraya
geldiğimizde arkadaşlar burası bizim
için yine en önemli kısımlarından bir
tanesi oluyor. Eee burada özellikle aset
kısmını doğru yönetmek o kadar önemli ki
yani bu yine projenin bence en önemli
kısımlarından değil en eee gerçekten
dikkat etmeniz gereken kısımlardan bir
tanesi. Bir arkadaşlar biz bir şey
yapıyorsak biz klosörlemeyi her yani bir
yaklaşım varsa her yerdedir bu yaklaşım.
Ya mesela sen içeride kenar arkite
kullanıp buraya gelip ilk vb diye ya da
işte v ikon diye olmaz. Bu bir
düşüncedir. Çünkü düşünce bir yerde
olmaz. Her yerde olur ve e bunları ona
göre geliştirmen lazım. Ona göre
götürmen lazım. Bunlar da basit
şeylerdir. B gördüğünde basit dersin ama
işte o an geliştirmiyorsan ilerlemez.
Neyse bu assetlerinizde yapacağımız
hareketler arkadaşlar basit olarak
projenin ihtiyaçlarını doğru yerde doğru
formata getirmek. Mesela ben ikonlarımı
bir yerde toplamak adına burada ikon
klasörü oluşturacağım. Mesela fontlarımı
burada toplamak adına font klasörü
oluşturup şunların hepsini buradan hop
buraya alacağım mesela gibi mesela
ikonlarımı aldım, fontlarımı aldım.
Mesela ben burada animation'larımı
alıp bunun içerisinde Loty'yi buraya
ayırt edeceğim. Mesela gif'lerim ki
olması çok takdir etmem. Gif'lerim varsa
buraya alacağım. Ve bu sayede mesela
ikonlarımın içerisinde de arkadaşlar SVG
ikonum olabilir, PNG ikonum olabilir.
Bunları burada yerine koyacağım ve günün
sonunda arkadaşlar buradan geldikten
sonrasında
bu SVG'lerimi de mesela şuraya alıp hop
buraya yerleştireceğim. Peki bunu
kullanırken nasıl kullanmam gerekiyor?
demem lazım ki mesela bu aircraft'a ilk
mesela ikon olarak düşündüğüm için air
aircraft
sv şeklinde olması lazım. Veya buradan
yine ilk eee neydi onun adı? İlk
connected word gibi olmalı ki hani
bunların hepsi kullanılmıyor da
düzelteyim.
F loading gibi olmalı ki ben buraya
baktığımda okuyup anlayabileceğim.
Mesela Loty de buraya geldi. Mesela bu
Loty de böyle çok görüyorum random
isimlerle. Bunun ne olduğunu
hatırlamıyorum ama bu loadingir
muhtemelen. Buraya loty lot lot lot da
yapabilirsiniz. Lottiy diye bir master
atıp lotty loading de diyebilirsiniz.
Buraları önemli olan bu hareketleri ya
da animation deyip lotinin adına
toplayabilirsin vesaire. buraya almak.
Şuraya baktığımda çünkü ben böyle
görmektense hani buraya gelip he ben
nelerimi alıyorum bunun içerisinden?
Asetimin içerisinde mesela
animation'ımın animation altında
gif'lerimi veya burada lottilerimi
buraya alıyorum. Tamam bu güzel. Ondan
sonra SVC'ler ikonumun altında varsa
ikonumun altındaki ikonu yazamadım. Eee
SVC'lerimi alıyorum.
Tamam. Süper. Yine varsa burada setimin
altında yine başka kullandığım imajlarım
vesairedir. Bunları da burada arkadaşlar
toplayıp projenin şu kısmını doğru
yönetime, doğru temiz bir şekilde
ilerletiyorum. Çünkü bir T senaryosunda
bunları eee düzenlemeniz gerektiğine
gerçekten çok zor oluyor.
İsimlendirmeleri doğru yapmak önemli. Bu
noktada da yine bir proje
geliştiriyorsanız veya geliştirmişseniz
yakın zamanda da çok sevdiğim
paketlerden bir tanesi olan şu
like'larımda gözükecektir.
Aa bu like'ları niye böyle yapmışlar?
Ranking değil. En son yaptı recentli
updateğim.
E aa gelmedi buraya. Just falan değil de
şuradan vardı. E p cleaner böyle p
cleaner tarzı yazarsanız flutter asset
cleaner up gibi. Bak bu da yeni çıkmış
herhalde arkadaş daha 3 saat önce
yollamış. Bu da mesela muhtemelen bu bu
tarz paketler var bu içeride. Bunlar
şunu sağlıyor. İşte ikonları
kullanılmayan ikonları temizleme,
paketleri temizleme gibi hareketleri
var. Ondan dolayı bunları da burada
entegre ederek kullanılmayan projedeki
asetlerinizi vesairenizi burada
konfigüre edebilirsiniz. Yine fontlar
dediğim gibi fontları zaten biz bir yere
koyduk. Fontları burada tek bu şekilde
verip projenin ana hattını
kurabilirsiniz. Burada ekstra bir
noktamız yok. Burada arkadaşlar dikkat
etmemiz gereken eee bunu da build
generation başlığı altında anlatacağım.
PUPML altında koyacağımız build
generation paketleriyle de burayı daha
efektif, daha kullanımlı hale
getireceğiz. Ama 35 aşağı temel anlamda
PUPC yamını bu şekilde yönetmeye
başlayıp projenin structurını da burada
bu şekilde kuruyorum diye giderseniz ve
paket update'lerini, şapkalarını işte
şurada yapacağım hareketleri
düzeltirseniz bu sizin için çok güzel ve
ilerleyici olacaktır. Yani bu tabii
production projelerinde ya da yapılan
işlerin durumuna göre burada daha farklı
hareketler, daha durumsal hareketler
olabilir. Ama burada en çok dikkat
etmeniz gereken kullanım standardını
belirlemek. hangi paketlere gideceğini
belirlemek. Mesela burada bir asset gen
paketini entegre edecek miyim? Hani
buraya asset gem paketleri mesela gen
paketlerini mesela kullanımda burada
nasıl kullanacağım? Bunları ben size
yine başlık olarak anlatacağım. Bunları
belirleyip akışı doğru kurguluyor
olmanız lazım. Ama eee mesela yine
burada son eee söyleyeceğim. Bu başlık
altında dikkat etmeniz gereken şey
paketleri kullandığınızda özellikle
paketleri kafadan atmak yerine
paketlerin ne kadar update aldığını, ne
sürede olduğunu ve eee bu paketlerin
duruma göre size nerede avantajlar
sağlayacağını görmeniz gerekiyor diyorum
arkadaşlar. Ve burada hatta kanalda da
benim bir içeriğim var. Paket oku paket
olma diye. Kullandığınız bütün
paketlerden aslında siz sorumlusunuz.
Yani paket sorun çıktı diye bir
müşteriye laf söylenmez. Ya bir gün
bazen oluyor öyle geliyor diyor mesela
eee neydi onun adı? Müşteri işte
projesinde şöyle şöyle bir şey var ya da
şu paketten. Biz de diyoruz ara şimdi
yan olmasın pakette sorun var diye. Ama
doğru bir yaklaşım değil. Çünkü pakette
sorun olması seni ilgilendirmez. Sen 10
aydır projeye çalışmış paralar
kazanmışsın o pakette kazanıyorsun ya
adama para vermiyorsun. Paket sayına
para vermiyorsun sonuçta. Yani aslında
eee iyi bir projede arkadaşlar
kullandığınız paketlere, kullandığınız
yerleri olabiliyorsanız contribü
olamıyorsanız ayrılık veya belli
periyotlarda bakıp varsa problemleri
alıp şey yapmanız gerekiyor. Tabii
bunlar biraz hayal satmak gibi de bazen
söyleniyor bana ama bunları ben
konuşuyorum. Nereye kadar alabilirseniz
o kadar iyi. Şimdi ben burada normalde
analiz option'a da geçecektim ama
geçmekten vazgeçtim. Sadece pubpack
kontrolünü başlık olarak alıyorum. Böyle
içeriyi çok böyle küçük küçük
götüreceğim. büyüdükçe o zaman
okunmuyor. Ondan dolayı buraya şey
diyeceğim. Bir tane hemen branch
alacağım. Eee, PU SPC diye şu şekilde.
En azından PUBSpack'in birinci kısmını
konuşmuş olduk. Eee, bunları bir
comit'leyip yollayayım arkadaşlar. Siz
de isterseniz eee, kendi tarafınızda
bunları çekersiniz. Eee, bu bizim şey
çalışmıyor olabilir. Heh, geldi. Süper.
Bunu da yolladım. Eee, yine repo
üzerinden şurada createimi de yapayım.
Repo üzerinden arkadaşlar bu ilgili e
1inci PR'ımız da gelmiş oldu. Buradan da
erişip e buraya arkadaşlar şeyinizi
yapabilirsiniz. Şunları da alalım. Son
zamanda şuraya da bug'ımızı da açalım.
Feature olarak verelim. Enchantment
olarak. Ben buraya kopilotumu da
ekliyorum. Ben her zaman için onu
ekliyorum son zamanlarda. Bu şekilde
yine buradan bu yaptığım geliştirme ve
durumlara erişebilirsiniz arkadaşlar.
Eee teşekkür ediyorum. Bir sonrakinde
artık şunun yanına dan atayım. Şöyle eee
checkbox var mı? Şöyle
eee şöyle atamıyorum.
Şurada emojilerden down var mıymış?
Done. Hı.
Süper. Bir tanesini yapmış olduk.
İkincisi de önemli. Üçüncüsü hepsinin
kendine göre önemi var. Ona göre konuşa
konuşa arkadaşlar eee bu
entegrasyonlarımızı devam ediyor
olacağız. Şimdiden herkesin arkadaşlar
dinleyen sevgili arkadaşlar elinize
emeğinize sağlık kolay gelsin diliyorum.
Basit bir başlık gözükebilir ama
gerçekten projenin durumuna ve şey
yerine göre çok önemli olabiliyor.
Tekrardan diğer içerikte görüşmek üzere
arkadaşlar. Yeah.